(ethereal music)
(water churns softly)
(hair brushes)
(toothbrush brushes)
(water runs)
(pan sizzles)
- My name is Sonja Hyppanen,
and I'm born in Finland
and I've been with Sea
Shepard for five years now.
My training from uni is journalism.
I still go back to that job.
- [Woman] By far most of the
people within Sea Shepard
are volunteers even if this is a massive,
global organization, it's not so much like
I'm in the military or whatever.
I just protect what's closest to my heart.
(soft piano music)
- [Man] The open ocean is a lawless area.
The UN is just starting
to address that now.
- [Man] There's not
many organizations left
that do what they do and
go thousands of miles,
you know, trying to protect the
marine life in the waters.
(soft piano music)
- [Man] Just like the
strength of an ecosystem
is in diversity, the
strength of any movement
lies in diversity.
So this is why we're a
volunteer organization.
- [Man] And I think
okay we say we come here
with a motivation, it's
beyond motivation and to be
committed to something that's right.
(people chatter)
(soft music)
- [Man] If you look on
the earth as a spaceship,
which is what it is, we're
traveling around the galaxy,
every spaceship has a life support system
and our life support system
is that biodiversity,
especially in the ocean.
(ethereal music)
- [Man] The land is small.
You know, it’s 30-percent of this whole
planet and that's what
we think of, "Oh the land."
You know, but the ocean, really
the planet is the ocean.
- [Man] The ocean provides
us everything
that we need to survive.
It produces oxygen, it produces food,
regulates climate and temperature.
(ethereal music)
- [Man] Well it gets back
to that essential mantra
that if the oceans die, we die.
(harpoon explodes)
But the power of money and consumption
has been overriding all of that.
- [Man] They've always said that they're
conducting scientific research.
So the International Code
of Justice underlined that.
They basically said that
what whalers are doing
is in fact a poaching operation.
(radio mumbles)
- [Man] There's not
these surpluses of stuff
lying around in the ocean, it's all there
in the amount that it needs
to be for the ocean to live.
(gulls cry)
(clocks tick)
- [Man] So Sea Shepard
steps in in accordance
with the United Nations
World Charter for Nature.
- [Man] So we enforce the
International Conservation Law
against illegal fishing (mumbles).
- [Radio] Yeah I've got a
radar target hit about nine miles.
- [Radio] Did you see
anything over that way?
(radio mumbles)
It definitely looks
like a ship on the radar
so it looks like about 11 o'clock.
(radio mumbles)
(bell rings)
- [Radio] Dispel crew, dispel crew.
Close all dampers, close all dampers.
Meet at station, meet at station.
(bell rings)
(suspenseful music)
- [Man] It's not just a
protest, it's not just
banner waving or petition signing,
it's getting physically involved
and making a difference.
- [Radio] You can bring
in the defensive lines.
(mumbles) in the water.
(suspenseful music)
- [Man] Do you have all
the lines nice and tight?
(mumbles)
We are going in the water.
- [Man] It's challenging
the system and the system
is in favor of the bureaucracy.
- They are ready to deploy.
- [Man] And when you try
and stand up against that,
it's odd the reaction you get.
- [Man] Try and go and close it.
Make a (mumbles).
(radio mumble orders)
- [Man On Loud Speaker] You are whaling
illegally in these waters.
You have been condemned by the
International Code of Justice.
(dramatic music)
- [Man] To be honest, if we
were doing the wrong thing,
the Sea Shepard would be shut down.
I wouldn't be able to volunteer.
- [Man On Loud Speaker] Your
acts are not in accordance
with the international rules of the road.
What you are doing is illegal,
we are doing nothing wrong.
You're crossing our port side,
you're crossing our port side.
You must give way.
- [Radio] Please brace for
collision, brace for collision.
(radio mumbles frantically)
(boats crash)
- [Woman] Stop, stop.
(gun fires)
(water sprays.)
- [Man On Loud Speaker] You have purposely
endangered our crew
and damaged our vessel.
Change your course to port
to prevent further damage.
(people yell excitedly)
- [Radio] The whole fishing
vessel aside your starboard.
- [Man On Loud Speaker] You're fishing
illegally in these waters.
- [Man] People just came up and were like,
"What are you guys?
"What is what you're doing?"
And just couldn't figure it out at all
with the jolly and the
logos and everyone in black.
- [Woman] We only go
against illegal operators
so with authorities, we
do everything by the book.
It's very important
for us to be recognized
as a legitimate law enforcement force.
- [Man] Many of them have
never been to sea before.
Many of them have never done
anything like this before.
- [Woman] The ocean is not
very well at the moment.
It's pretty sick and needs a lot of help.
(sad ethereal music)
- [Man] So really what we're talking about
is a movement to save
ourselves from ourselves.
- [Man] Everybody doing okay?
Anybody want to go get some rest?
(soft music)
- [Woman] We have people who
are 18, people who are 65.
They're artists, they're
lawyers, they're plumbers,
journalists, different
religious backgrounds.
You know, I’m just a normal girl from a little town.
(soft music)
How I perceive the world,
everything's connected.
Your oceans are connected to the land
which is connected to the people
so if we keep depleting the fish stocks
with overfishing, illegal fishing,
there's no food for people on the planet.
(train rumbles)
I do believe every human being is
good at their hearts, so
if you give them the correct
information they will change.
And I think it's something
I've been looking for
the whole of my life, how I can make a
direct impact for the
well-being of the planet.
(string orchestral music)
- [Man] Come along you!
Oh, here it is!
Here it is!
Wooo!
(string orchestral ethereal music)
- [Man] Sea Shepard can't
spend the next 50 years
in the Antarctic policing
the anti-whaling campaign,
but also the governments can't afford it,
so we have to educate the people that
it's not the right thing to do
and that is the way forward.
- [Man] There's almost
a key moment to join
any sort of fight that is
gonna try to bring a change.
Everything counts in this
very moment of history.
- [Man] We're not here to be pessimistic
'cause we know we've
got something to save.
If there's nothing to
save we wouldn't be here.
- [Man] It's not like you get
another chance at these things.
You know, once it's gone, it's
very often, that's it.
(ethereal music)
(piano music)
- We don't try to say that Sea Shepard's
gonna save the world
We're not.
But we can set an example for others.
- Met a lot of really
great passionate people
and it's nice to just be part of something
where people haven't given up hope.
- It's not a point where we can't move
forward positively, absolutely not.
And I think the fight is a good one
and it's just education.
(piano music)
- When people get to
know about Sea Shepard,
it's mostly you know them from TV,
you know the direct actions.
- The media can transport
quite a different
image of what this organization is about
and what we actually do.
- People know us from the
anti-whaling campaigns
in the Antarctic, but of
course, we've done a lot more.
- I'll walk into a room
and they'll look at me
and they'll go, "Wow, we didn't
think you'd look like that."
(piano music)
- You have to work with
so many different people
depending on their background,
depending on their education or their
religion, their culture.
- They're as good as any professional crew
I've ever witnessed because
they want to be there.
They're not just in it for the money.
- This is exactly the reason why
I wanted to join Sea Shepard using
direct action and not just witnessing
illegal activities happening or injustice
happening in our oceans.
- And that's what I
think makes us so strong
that we can make the
bond between everybody
and then work together when there are
situations that we need to do actions in.
(piano music)
- I think it's interesting
how they always say it's
eco-terrorists and pirates
and all these different things
and yet I turn in my sea
time to the U.S. Coast Guard.
At every port I have to
clear in with the Police
so I'm never arrested.
- The Sea Shepard are, you know, pirates
and they stand up against.
You go, "Well, that's one opinion.
“And every issue has two sides to it."
- I meet a lot of young
people who see through this
and they are the ones who I think will be
starting to change.
- The movement doesn't have any leaders.
When I look around the world,
all the great social achievements
have been done by individuals.
- Well it brings together
people from all walks of life.
- Older people, younger people.
Uh, you know, some crazy people.
(laughs)
But, yeah, just, you know, people like you and me
in a day to day, whatever.
(piano music)